okay guys okay I [ __ ] is beautiful
[ __ ] beautiful bastard whatever they
say these days whatever they say to say
that cabs gonna continue hopefully we
just [ __ ] and get back tracked with wait
okay so riff to last let me remember
okay let's say I think we're just
explicitly dat dick we just explore the
town sitting here
now usually ask mom though create loss
though Halloween okay she usually asked
like what we're doing today
we could always do that if we're [ __ ]
[ __ ] but I'm not like [ __ ]
[ __ ] so when one is this new lamp we
should harvest fast he's hardly still
missing
yeah yeah it bounces that just patches
like this teddy
and that guy look at me in that car goes
on the old pickaxe sippys up still yeah
baby what up baby ma we've got and I got
a lot of rocks off the metal came in
earlier this year and like a crap load
of snow shell but using the distro
places grew up like this they returned
by weather was it yeah it's not that
serious so what's up what I have tonight
and work at me like come along Oh think
if we go like tough spot as a hundred
maybe that's actually not a bad idea of
a Saigon we're touching the stupid point
paycheck reps who administer menacing do
want to come along enough yeah that's a
new thing check a good hanging up yeah
[Music]
let's see what Greg's up to Gregory what
you up to [ __ ] what are you up
to beautiful bastard and that you
when the class is an ending some [ __ ] I
know what you do know you tellin ya Greg
shuts up mmm a totally what's up to do
we think might go to jail like you're
planning on going I think I could break
out maybe actually like test my skills
escape I feel the risk is bigger than
any possible reward from success had
nightmare echo energy i'm a cousin went
to jail and my other cousin Jim said it
was inevitable you mad men rule means
it's not investable dr. back I
definitely didn't have a little Greg
thing is around today now he's off your
stuff sometimes a headband stuff
genetics or talk about she's gonna hang
out and as well that's straight
mechanics like I love mechanics to pull
it wet calayan the room you can still
see the bullet hole in it how does not
kill him looking at all important parts
of the brain yeah great great grand is
free stuff but is it that the helmets
the factors were wearing that wrong war
and we're all country he's worth the bad
guys keep a nice trick make it guess
what when you learn all this stuff have
people kept saying it was a fascist hat
so we do with idiot for crime boy am I
ever I mean kind of distant last night
without me after yeah I always went up
world karate this beautiful boobs like
five so what's the plan follow me a chef
Ranger cleaned up yeah I wasn't moved
for us what you need the best for da da
la at that car up from risky so you
brought me out me here to watch me beat
up a car is that is this like a thing
where people are all hot for car crashes
now and I don't know that moving look it
up yeah so let me the battery out of
this car before that privileges grow
private call me private I'm a generalist
now I'm the general I got a hat more
stupid watch it we got me this hat okay
what is for my niece's car I think it's
safe to say no one's going to miss it
yeah I guess we've got a trigger on
through it
so we're just going to be beating it up
up to the hope hops of it it smash it up
Master all up mass capitalism smash the
government that this car yep [ __ ]
yourself excellent work thank you like
right you want to do the honors Megan
lots of cute it should be fun guys got a
tree growing through it probably not
electric anymore wait what you want to
do it a nap I do
okay get rid of leave out of the white
[ __ ] out of the way jasa okay yeah
[Music]
hello hey Chaka what are you doing here
you've always been a good friend I every
day you visit remember the quickly just
to say hello get some an excellent
friend charcoal my desk that I think
let's go back your master great thing
really not really now yeah rocking a lot
here I don't feel bad shut your cake see
it died hello as I am like five seconds
weird have like stretches this with
steroids universe we get to go the
battery you think you know let's get
back to the apartment I take pennies and
anyway even if it wasn't fashion helmet
it's got an era q simple on it now which
makes it good and there's a bullet hole
in it so whoever it was wearing it is
dead and I'm like wearing the trophy she
admit that's not fashion how much yeah I
don't okay so what are we doing ok so
right questions to hell is that
the thing yes obviously today there were
those big like robot cartoon characters
they used to have a matsusaki I do oh my
god is that one of them as we going to
put one together do if we tell they are
this is amazing where the hell did you
get it you know Steve stringham the guy
who locked the substitute teacher at
supply Colin yeah yeah dude he was stuck
in there over the longest night break
survived by eating fluent spanish book
Brooks these cricket gave you this that
guy it's horrible man he's hanging
around the food donkey since we could
shut down and he dug it out for me if
it's the first useful think Steve has
ever done okay okay okay what do we do
and we need to get this little battery
two little things that straightforward
enough kind of school garbage read you
didn't cut yourself on and get us to use
to bed needed by the way here to bet the
robot was until Thank You snakes and
they killed you these are the elevators
in fall squash like a pancake dude
that's not that the phobia that one
makes sense that way
what we're doing in
[Music]
I think so yeah like something was
living in here
what are you stop being so negative once
you get your neck that's impossible be
serious this is serious business so a
lot of gel I'm a they've already died
once tonight no big deal or anything
what was it like I saw shark I think and
it told me something important what was
it and I remember couldn't have in that
point then true okay let's do it [ __ ]
[ __ ]
James no safe here we have blurring out
just because you guys feel like a whole
five seconds dead come on some people
have a dead for like ever it will see
that Wyman right to shut up and deal
it's become ghosts are you saying I
should become a go yeah I'm for damn
[ __ ] okay stay up look who's all fancy
friends now okay what are we doing that
was the best part we are going to put
this piece together you know how it goes
together going to find a patch cough
next block sorry who's here the parts
[ __ ] slapping together types of skirts
let's go
okay bet now let's do this guy ok so
like [ __ ] horrifying
[Music]
okay that's a fish that's [ __ ] scared
it's perfect to a beautiful boy robot
zot so like this pretty great alpha
remind me why don't we just put a bunch
of garbage together the living room and
connect to school car battery to really
catch it on the carpet I think I know
since you've been back in town I think I
miss Gregg for a few years ago like
these days I mostly work all the time
but while you work it so much we got
plans will play right harbor right hi
back when a year or so then that's what
working like seven days a week but when
are you moving I think it was spring
that's like a few months away yeah okay
you should come visit when we gets a
little bit why Brad harbor it's so cold
visited with summer there's like record
stores and word Boz and everyone's cool
like free that's why I got my tattoo
what yeah a shame is that a shape yeah I
shape that suit guy was like all the way
hot and it didn't even hurt you have a
tattoo you're moving to Bret Hart yeah
okay all right anyway yeah like I was
saying now that you're back a thousand
springs I was like hey let's do some
crime again out good yes so think about
how to use that for like good so I
thought I'd bring this here for Angus
that's beautiful dude i'm sure i love it
i hope so
okay so yeah all we need to do now is
turn it up I want to push the button let
me push the button let me do it see the
least I can do for my best friend back
to the dead piece of part of next time i
die come back dude that's such a deal
the wait okay it's absolutely worth help
whatever was living here in this hole I
can't think I see you push your [ __ ] ok
I can push this book as other ways that
just gets crap crap like that yeah
[ __ ] it [ __ ] this
hi hater I guess how's it going that it
has time yes yes yes so I like here for
Bob that's ok ok hello father how's work
you know better than the glass factory
isn't I've mind Iran machine but now I
get the slide stakes and hawks alarm is
I mean it's easier the backlash too sure
but like you like it I like having a
paycheck their paycheck to swedish
meatball second time to go [ __ ] play
bad time absolutely yeah 99 section of
ninety nine straight days oh we're gonna
have a [ __ ] dream again plays that
they kind of like craving sketch it as a
running back up James sure
oh stop it there I'm all about this
budget I can all about that
and then kept talking far
take this thank you
and who play here for the birthday
down there near maybe that's just over
here that I should know about any
visitors over here that
hey over here
music is popping a nice joint
make I got some chance and I have up for
sure now I need a cheap [ __ ] exact
ethically
ok
it's [ __ ] disgusting
just hanging here that yeah
okay I got sick people and forgot
anything
a lot of music playing tonight that's
for sure
okay i have not gone backwards after get
my lanta
so we get back
what set
and [ __ ] except not all right yes
they go all the way out here
here I kept at that guy
there is some rappelling
just stuff that you just jump just to
piss jump jump jump jump jump jump yes
so just a bunch of [ __ ]
then I go up here did I go up here
I think I said yes I think I did
yeah went that way
ok
breath all around here
it's like a junkyard of Brecon drain
[Music]
[ __ ] tomorrow night
[Music]
anything about this well anything but
the squirrel it was on the computer
check it hey bench I might work all day
I just saying I want to say hello I'm
here to be hello that update the robots
nose will be naturally mr. anyway hit by
a work called a very bored work sucks
crap talking more like it see Abby's off
20 if you fix it
hey my mouth yawn morning long night yep
remember those big robot things in food
donkey yes scared of those quite a lot
eyes at my man was that bad i don't
remember to set up yeah okay yeah the
Dearborn's up stuff kind of adult stuff
yeah just like budget bills numbers shut
up don't hold his number stress that
sounds bad I'm bad numbers I remember I
can win head out have a nice hey [ __ ]
gets a codex on my personally my dad's
back oh yeah baby yeah yeah baby yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
recipes catchphrase I just get it
advances Tyra you know better there's
that guy said left gonna work again I
can Angus Angus and see our kind of
suspect no where's my best friend where
is he doin today what's it go in today
hey hang video app out of town
pastabilities thankful for that close
enough
nag back
hey bad hey let's go guys good what's up
with you I'm gonna do something okay wow
she's like all the coffee I can't have
some expensive taste good that was once
because of sugar go out a hassle to make
something surf it's okay go do something
yeah man let's go what are we doing now
well okay I'll share the safe
it's p delta I really sick classes
pretty tough if you a thing
I like that very tranquil
and I should have brought my water
bottle on here
you
get up here
licensed enjoy the shower when I hang up
that says oh hey there's let's just
let's put the ditches and haters put our
hands together you know more
yes
yeah yeah yeah
wow that's beautiful dad it's like a kid
you can get off the internet generally
put it together so it's a motorcycle now
yeah take a water ice bike that is
different so you got dirt back again I'm
going to solve that I ride a bike so
like wearing it was night in the woods
it's [ __ ] scary though doom doom doom
bill bill bill bill bill La Brea
Valhalla across the die [ __ ] is a snap
we're going to break a leg and have to
call back to town or dad like bears
release tonight yeah yeah you going with
cuts all over and so done well I but I
got nasrin dad you're saying post [ __ ]
yeah you're on first of us out three
times losses come get cut [ __ ] say
goodbye to your fingers I'm going to
[ __ ] you up you [ __ ] that may want to
shame on you that made Bret shame on I
personal what's that three times like
that [ __ ] [ __ ] cut your hand up
a [ __ ] stab you betcha on the east
side [ __ ] ah you cut me to date geez
[ __ ] it now that I'm not okay we can
now again again okay ready ready Beckett
yeah [ __ ] go go go go Wow betch you
[ __ ] that's I can count my bets right
yeah yeah Wow set Oh [ __ ] egg or kill
each other here thinking a necklace a
man that explains my parents attacked by
a dog against now the FBI had a knife
right it's got [ __ ] I got you you
tagged my life is done let me here to
bleeding all over place let's cap one
last time pet is that I'm ready ready
ready yeah yeah yeah coo coo coo goes we
go no your [ __ ] ass off
ten little Rosa I might check it defines
I don't like nice bite much I want to
either if I was bad at it by hand
probably not stopping for today [ __ ]
bloody wait why did you have to not good
question let's break this log nice now
probably going to kill step 1 ready go
go go go let's stab each other some more
for Slenderman yes though yeah yeah let
me see a rat entry log except in the
woods more like his eyes on a big rock
like you have to kick the tree over
break the ice like I can't not do that
yeah yeah so like like feel if it's
different now like a moving blood it
feels great because I was here yeah okay
yeah that makes sense these woods will
never be the same man I changed that got
blood all over them we change them but
if I thank you someone could have died
or get formed because you broke that
like crap and yeah let's get up late in
that head on here i can get out [ __ ] is
that is that a real animal ok he's going
to share it great dad loves the
different side of the guy thing down
sign I guess yeah I miss much about my
dad and uncle and cousin I shout turkey
yeah not bad anyway we like to bin ass
at least in the shoot this can tell like
what's the good deal with the forest got
like in the story yeah looks like it's
just suck a bunch of targets of decoys
together you work bang bang with what
you got you want to shoot it dude yeah
you go stand in front and I electric
over your head dude ok I get it
yes I got them yeah let's kill thank you
a real bird and it's a pretty sad pretty
good you can while these bars up there
it goes kind of kill these birds out
there like [ __ ] a debuff to school
that's fine look at here channa keeps
shining tonight their eyes again I've
[ __ ] for one day fuxee going to murder
me what pieces [ __ ] killed me
[Music]
so notice yeah it's been happening
lately but what has electrical stuff
like we basically died twice last night
no I think that's on you so don't wanna
be nosey but you seem a little up and
down today yeah it's a thing I mean it's
a thing is general lately but I'm a good
person right yeah sure I don't know
what's up man try really hard Angus like
needs me he needs a Greg badly things
trouble something's now it's like gettin
had the best life his family is like
pure trash and so just like [ __ ]
really stupid [ __ ] I just don't ever
want to lose him not ever I don't know
what I do I don't want to screw this up
you doona risky antic that's a mark of
it lately at what that's tough period
but I'm just talking about trash I know
that I'll love I've got no future if it
was just like when I wake at night I
listen I Angus snow and I stare at the
ceiling and I think about how complete
vicious [ __ ] and grant crack house out
this year good and is good
yeah thank you sooo good nice two mar
high school dude I'm chills etc etc you
know he's got that ass that got thank
you for finally saying it's a fantastic
astray fantastic okay I'm not
comfortable with you objectify my
boyfriend Tony's ass and who could blame
you
I want Dennis I forget what I was going
to say i don't know probably worried
about nothing I've really up up days and
really down down days not know which it
is on some is overdue I kind of coast
through on general blah right now
kind of burglars have no idea hey Burt
northern dump file he should skinny bad
as I blacked out you want me to make
something up yeah yeah that's good
that's real good
let's go how much
yeah okay we're doing another sleeping
at manukau will call it an end yes baby
that's a typo you want you suck face
what's happening now now my way James
okay they should have been left to me
a version
yet
and I really like to fly like a trainer
I think it's a train
and pick up all right
I think Reese Catholic colleges
you
it is it
don't know boil away again
worth of damage
boiler
train I like a building tree box
but
musician
yes
ok
nothing
ok
ok
great
allowed a musician
listen
right now here's a nightmare feel there
we go
[Music]
but is it is time
you
[Music]
like that and i like that bash so all
right we're going to edit here then
folks it's been nice it's been real nice
ok really thank y'all people set yeah